welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Paul North a professor of Germanic
language and literature at Yale he has
written numerous articles and books
including the problem of distraction he
is also co-editor of idiom inventing
writing theory a book series at Fordham
University Press today we'll talk with
professor north about his new book the
yield Kafka's a theological Reformation
welcome professor North thank you it's
nice to see you here with us today and
this should be I'm sure a very
interesting topic for us today so let's
begin with your book tell us about it
well the book is a presentation of a
very strange text written by Franz Kafka
who most people know they've read him in
America at least in high school some
creepy stories but in 1917 responding to
a lot of pressures and changes in his
environment in Prague he wrote a
theoretical text which to my mind is on
par with the great philosophical and
theoretical texts of the European
tradition so that this book reconstructs
this text which tells you what the basic
elements of reality are it tells you
what to do in your life it tells you
where Humanity is headed all sorts of
big questions are answered by Kafka in
this book okay and is this a book that
has it been published or no his book
yeah he works
yeah the text is a strange text it was a
set of thoughts that occurred to him
over half a year while he was staying
outside of Prague a sort of small farm
that his sister was living on and he
devoted himself to the state of mind
in which thoughts would occur to you in
some sense being away from Prague away
from his commitment stopping writing
fiction allowed him to have these
thoughts but they're preserved only as
individual thoughts so my book
reconstructs the whole schema in which
they make sense as a critique of
European commitments okay and how did
you become interested in the topic what
led you to write this book I what led me
to write the book mmm I would say three
things one is there was I've worked a
lot in this period in European thought
and there was a general sense that
everything was going downhill this is
the early 20th century in middle Europe
between the wars World War one was a
kind of game changer for people's
attitudes towards the tradition and what
happened all the instability that
happened between them also brought up
kind of a need for formulating a new way
of living in Europe new political
theories were being born new
philosophical systems were being born
but no one had investigated Kafka's so
it seemed to be calling out for a
reconstruction also it presents a very
very odd new perspective on things how
so well the aim of Kafka's treatise in
thoughts is to convince us not to do
anything not to do anything okay to do
as little as possible or you could say
even less than nothing and why why does
he why is he telling us this it is a bit
of a strange response to everything he
was experiencing and everything he had
read the tradition he felt and a lot of
people had felt had come to a dead end
the European tradition the Kafka was at
least nominally through his family
Jewish and had this very strange sort of
three-sided identity problem he was a
German speaker in Prague among Czech
speakers and a Jew among German speakers
Kafka among humanity and you might
understand a little bit about that if
you've read some of Kafka's writings he
was his imagination kept him outside of
most of the political and social norms
that we take for granted so there were
responses to these problems what to do
with Europe what to do with the
tradition what is an intellectual to do
in a time of great upheaval but also
what what should the Jews do and one of
the main responses was political Zionism
go to Palestine and establish a state
like other European states in Kafka
being Kafka and having this three-sided
identity problem didn't commit to any of
those solutions to what he saw as a very
dire situation all of his friends the
novelist max brought his friend Felix
belch who was a philosopher were
involved in Zionist projects of one sort
or another they were in the circle of
people listening to Martin Buber who was
a cultural Zionist but political Zionism
that is establishing a state outside of
Europe was still a very powerful idea
Kafka said no to all of these things he
also said no to being a kind of building
a Jewish community in diaspora
he thought that building anything was
exactly what the Jewish Bible taught not
to do so what he does in this set of
thoughts as he goes back to the Jewish
Bible goes back to the book of Genesis
and he starts pulling out lessons from
there that are absolutely opposite to
what everyone else was doing in the day
advocating a move an establishment of a
state or building a Jewish culture in
diaspora so can you cite any of the text
he was pulling - sure I can tell you a
little bit about the central one he was
very concerned with the myth of paradise
myth the story of paradise the legend of
paradise this very central biblical
tail and he spends a long time in his
treatise and thoughts showing that the
logic of paradise simply doesn't hold up
one of the thoughts is something like
this if paradise could have been
destroyed then it wasn't paradise if it
was destroyed then wait so much for my
memory Paradise was destroyed then it
wasn't paradise if it wasn't destroyed
then we were never expelled from
paradise to begin with the point is that
the history that seems to go from this
initial fall and then develop into human
history with its idea of progress can't
possibly be true if that's the case we
shouldn't act in order to make things
better because there's no there's no
trajectory of history from a fall to
redemption and that's mainly the central
argument of the book that if you read
Genesis carefully this is Kafka's
peculiar reading of Genesis if you read
it carefully there is no paradise at the
beginning and no Redemption at the end
okay so let's talk about the book title
the yield why did you select that as the
title the yield is a word that I'm using
to describe Kafka's advice Kafka's
advice is a certain kind of not acting
okay so to yield to yield and yielding
is the yield the product of thinking
through these thoughts with him and
yielding for him means a couple of
things it doesn't mean simply practicing
non-violence because for him
non-violence is already within a
framework of trying to improve the state
by let's say different means Kaka is
really thinking of a different kind of
community than a state and so
non-violence might be part of a
rebellion for example of the people
against a state to achieve a certain end
the Kafka's imagining a yielding way of
living
that would more or less ignore the state
altogether okay
let's talk a little bit more about his
writings tell us a little bit more about
you know some of his ideas that that you
came across and doing this book so Kafka
really developed as a writer once he got
his day job working for the workers
accident insurance company in Prague
that's the version austro-hungarian
Hungarian version of our OSHA they at
that time negotiated between businesses
and workers to try and keep the worker
safe and the businesses paying into the
insurance fund so that they could cover
injured workers and Kafka before that he
had been writing in this very
expressionist style of the day and
things really changed when he started
writing insurance texts although he
hated his job it really changed his own
style it became the kind of uncanny
cough conceal wear and the style doesn't
express the strangeness of what's
happening in the stories because he was
a lawyer and working in this agency he
encountered a lot of oddities about the
law about its application about its
interpretation and the first half of his
stories have a lot to do with the law
and also another minor motif in his
early stories and novels are families
and the particularly fathers but around
this time when he writes this set of
thoughts things change and he starts to
think about power so I think he realized
that behind these questions of
legitimacy legality interpretation and
behind the institution of the family and
the father with his particular mode of
legislating the family stood these
questions about Authority and power that
were even more nefarious and strange
ultimately than the law itself and he
starts with this text really shifting to
something like a critique of power and
his recommendation in this text is
simply not to use power not to use it at
all this I take to be the most radical
claim in these texts the texts
themselves are fragmentary they're
highly puzzling they take they are they
take a long time to figure out it many
many years to organize them and see how
they're related to one another but
basically they are thoughts like you or
I would have thoughts in the form that
we would have them written down directly
from the event of having thoughts in
their most puzzling form and left that
way can you tell are they chronological
did you is there a way to tell when
they're written yes it's them he dates
them and he reworks them when he selects
the ones he wants potentially to publish
although like most of Kafka's writings
they were never published and never even
sent to a publisher and then they belong
to the collection of papers that he
asked his friend max broad to burn at
the end of his life of course didn't
because he didn't because he was luckily
enough either to misunderstand that
request of Kafka's or to understand it
too well we have all of this great Kafka
immaterial and where where are these
papers today the papers except for two
of them are held at the Bodley and
library at Oxford I was there doing some
research and he wrote them on little
pieces of paper called settle and before
that he had written them down in small
notebooks that he carried with him on
his perambulations in a small town so
you would go to the library and read
through them and so let's go back to the
power you know to a shoe power did he
talk about if you were shoe power what
might happen or what should happen or
what society would be like right yeah
obviously he didn't foresee the Shoah
this was in 1917 so it was before
anything like that had entered anyone's
imagination some people's imagination
perhaps but
thing further than that and I don't
think he was thinking of it as a
political solution but as a way of
behaving in the in a situation in which
there was no clear solution in which any
response to anti-semitism to oppression
just strengthened the powers of
oppression so what could you do Kafka
really was a kind of logician and he
thought of these things as almost as
mathematical problems and his solution
to the problem was this practice of
yielding which was a personal practice
but he looked around and he saw it at
work in nature
he saw it at work in in history how does
it how does anything ever change well
some state of affairs has to give up its
position as preeminent so this is much
more of a theoretical position on
Kafka's part then let's say a practical
one right okay he did envision at the
same moment what he called the
possession less work force and part of
these texts are a critique of possession
a critique of private property of
property all the way up to the idea of
even having anything really yielding
means giving up that kind of greedy
grasp of anything including language or
your cultural conventions Kafka was very
extreme in his thoughts so he wrote this
what he called the possession 'less
workforce in which he designed a society
that was subsistence based where any
extra of anything went to the poor only
the healthy worked and only a certain
amount of hours enough to provide the
basic needs of the society Kafka was not
a very sophisticated student of the
history of social forms but in his kind
of pure fear theorization of the answer
to this problem the problem of power how
to live in a world in which your actions
don't Perpetua
wait power he came up with with this
idea okay be after the yield it's
Kafka's a theological Reformation right
what are you meaning by that okay so
Kafka had a particular relationship to
religious thought
in the Jewish Zionist movements there
was always some taking the past
seriously and taking central texts and
ideas from Judaism seriously Kafka did
the same thing but what he found when he
went back to Genesis was something that
didn't make sense and you could say in
the tradition of textual critique of the
Bible that there are many different
editors working there and different
strands of the Bible woven together and
the contradictions in the text arise
from that
but Kafka saw them as logical
contradictions what he saw was that the
basic tenets of European religions let's
say Christianity and Judaism to speak
very loosely because these are huge
traditions that all have all sorts of
contradictory elements at all sorts of
different moments in history anyway but
to say that very roughly Judaism and
Christianity that they begin from
confused principles so Kafka's a
theological Reformation is a critique of
the use of these principles by leading
them back to their confused origins one
of them being this question of paradise
the paradise idea is confused and can't
possibly be if it was it wouldn't have
been destroyed so we would be living in
paradise now if it wasn't paradise then
it was never destroyed we never lived in
paradise and we have no reference to
paradise to begin with this is the kind
of originally confusion that Kafka
thinks drives a lot of the violence and
ideology in European history so he
thinks if you can critique these and
draw them back to an original confusion
people can stop acting on the basis of
principles that don't make sense the way
to act on the basis of principles that
don't make
cents is to yield to give up acting at
least in any way that we recognize it
alright alright okay so your book is is
a little bit they're actually very
different from you know the thoughts on
Kafka that are out there let's talk
about that how are how is this book
different from others there are a few
books that deal with Kafka as a thinker
as a theorist and even the books that
deal with his literature his literary
writings have to confront someone who
was obviously thinking very profoundly
about certain philosophical questions
but basically Kafka criticism falls into
two camps those who are fascinated by
Kafka the person and go through his
biography to try to imagine how someone
like this could have come to be and the
other is those who are fascinated with
Kafka the writer who think of some kind
of magic of writing and go through his
writing and his comments on writing to
see how this sort of writing could have
come to be and those are interesting
questions and really illuminate Kafka
but I'm interested in the Kafka and
results there's a small body of work
that has the same interest but this
doesn't involve treating Kafka as a
philosopher exactly it really involves
taking his writing seriously as unique
as literary as being as much tied up
with the language as it is with some
abstract idea of a thought certainly the
language is is very important but we can
learn a lot from Kafka let's say that
and many people have emphasized the
parabolic nature of Kafka stories were
the possibility that one could always
interpret them yet again and I don't
think that's the case I think Kafka had
a project though it's I feel like it's
my mission in this book to present
Kafka's project for a world in which the
kinds of conflict that Kafka saw not
diminished at all certainly not in
Europe
well fascinating thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work was a pleasure for
more information about Professor North
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report led you be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale